[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think
philosophy of science can offer a lot to
contemporary society
um and i think this is often forgotten
and
i think it's badly needed actually and
needed more so
with each year so philosophers of
science
they learn they typically learn a bunch
of science
and so in my case i learned a lot of
physics when i was younger
others might learn biology or economics
and then they
you know participated in the
foundational issues that go on in those
fields
but if you think about what's going on
in society today you know you have all
of these
areas where you can see that just
further advances in the science
won't really help so think of something
something like the climate crisis
there's a lot of good work in climate
science of course and there are many
philosophical questions in climate
science
but really when you start to think about
you know what path you
you know a country should go or
companies should go or university should
go
and dealing with this you know you
quickly get to all these other questions
and that really are much more
philosophical in nature
and so you need somebody who has some
technical skills so they can understand
the science
but also a background training that
includes you know these different issues
and philosophy of science
but uh but also you know things like
ethics and
all the other things you get uh trained
with in a
philosophy a phd
so for instance with climate change you
know for instance in economics
you know you'll have all these
cost-benefit analyses about what
paths forward are the best ones they
might
they will all you know put in a
particular number
for how to discount the future harms and
and benefits where does that number come
from
uh it doesn't come from anything you you
look out at in the world
and so you need to you know discuss this
and so
you know it has real effects and so you
need to
uh you know somebody with the skills of
the skill set of philosophy of science i
think is is well equipped to look at
that because they can understand
the fine details of the economics but
also think uh
you know they have their head up outside
the
narrow domain of economics and we'll
look at ethics and
justice and things like that but that's
so
increasingly for everything you know so
we see philosophers of science
tackling issues of medicine we see them
tackling issues with data science with
you know bias and ai and algorithms
in particular when we think of the rise
of misinformation
that you know the public is getting
[Music]
it's a it's a really uh good question
uh and i can see it i can see both sides
of it and i
and actually some of the work i do is uh
exploring both sides of this so
on the one hand you know i i sit on the
international science council which is
the global voice of science
i sit on their panel on scientific
freedom and
scientific responsibility and there are
many
scientists throughout the world who are
really challenged in terms of their
scientific freedom
the type of science they do you know
gets them into
trouble with the government trouble with
you know different groups who harass
them
in some places people are jailed and
other places
they're silenced and so the
international science council
along with a bunch of other groups like
scholars at risk
will you know make statements and help
try to exert
international pressure to let these
scientists have their
their scientific freedom you know so
they should be able to
move have you know freedom of mobility
they should have freedom to
work on what they want to work on uh
they should have freedom to
public to publicly express
this science um and so some of the work
is actually
on whistleblowers who will make a
statement say about
pollution in some area that maybe is
unwelcome to a particular government
somewhere
you know they should be rewarded for
their courage in standing up
and saying something uh that they found
in their science around them being
persecuted
um but you know i do think that you know
the the
scientific freedom is is comes at a
uh you know this it's not a sort of one
to one
sort of thing but where you know you
buy your scientific freedom at the for
the price of it is that your work is um
toward the public good not every
scientist's work has to be
you know done you know explicitly for
the public good
if you're a mathematician and you work
in number theory it's going to be
hard to see how it's not going to help
poor children
find better more food or anything like
that but on the other hand it
is a a real good you know if we're
contributing to
public knowledge of anything um
and so but but yeah so but anyway the
idea is that the
the scientific freedom comes with a you
know that you should at least pursue the
science
in a socially responsible way um
and so then that that raises difficult
questions you know should you pursue
science other certain topics of research
that are
should be prohibited restricted well
that question sort of ill form because
you can
imagine a society where you had freedom
to pursue
everything but but maybe not every
research topic
but maybe not freedom yeah but maybe
there's nothing in that
that says that the government or
different funding agencies need to fund
it
and so for instance if you think you
know of topics like
uh racial differences with regard to iq
or that you know the philosophy of
science uh
philip kitcher you know famously said
that you know in the
in the us that sort of work
you know should not be maybe not not
allowed but not
not encouraged or funded because
whatever was found wouldn't be useful or
helpful to the
the least well-off in the society
and so there you can see that it's not a
sort of
heavy hand on the restricting scientific
freedom
but maybe more like us a soft hand say
you know not funding
that kind of thing um
there's also issues about some funding
sure the this is one thing i'm very
interested in right now
you know so so you have different
industry groups fun scientists
researchers not not just scientists
there's academic freedom meaning that
you have the freedom to take as
any type of funding you want even if
that funding is coming
from groups that are working explicitly
against the public good
and maybe or maybe you think well they
could take whatever funding they want
but
they should at least disclose that and
so we have
so i'm very um interested in getting
uh disclosure policies passed so it's
familiar
to most scientists and that that you
know if you give a talk or
you publish in a particular journal that
you'll have to disclose your
potential financial and non-financial
conflicts of interest
but that's not really uniform across
many different areas
and so there are many high-profile
scandals where
professors have basically done research
for hire
for fossil fuel industries and not
disclosed that
that to me is really just pretty
disgusting and and
there should be uh different sorts of
transparency
requirements so i like kind of sunshine
laws
thinking that regulations at
universities
where you know the i think that the
tried and true method
of dealing with dark money is to shine
light on it
it makes dark money less
useful to the industry
yeah so is is science dangerous some
some
people see science as dangerous and
you can really understand where people
come from when they think about this
you know so there are many proposals and
i've been working on some of these
through my institute where you have
technological advances that are dual use
now dual use science studios dual use
research and technology
is um you know a common thing i mean
in some sense everything is dual use you
know so a hammer you could use to
murder someone or you could build a
house for a homeless person with it
and so a hammer is dual use
but i think when people are thinking
about science becoming
being dangerous the idea is that there's
some scientific advances that where the
beneficial uses are are going to be
really small and the costs are really
potentially catastrophic so here think
about things like
climate geoengineering so there's
different methods where you could
try to engineer the climate some of them
are actually not science fiction
you know you could really start doing
this very soon if you wanted to
it would have an effect on the climate
you know we know
you know from looking at various
volcanoes
that they can have tremendous effects on
the climate
and you could mimic some of this
but if you did so you know all these
sort of ethical questions will come up
who would decide to do that who would
decide to continue to do it because if
you stop doing it it
could be a disastrous how would you
police this
there would be winners and losers uh
and this kind of thing you know so if
you mess with the climate you you will
change things for better in some areas
and worse in other areas
would the resulting distribution be just
uh would it benefit just the the rich
countries
so there's all sorts of questions like
that of course also in biology
so the institute for practical ethics
has had a project
on gene drives for a few years
and gene drives are a kind of new way of
doing genetic modification
you know old style gene modification
would just you know you'd modify the
individual
and they would either pass the trade on
or not
and you just have the kind of mendelian
inheritance patterns take over the
gene drive you can force the trait to
occur
in the offspring so you can just fill up
the whole
subsequent populations with that trait
so it
unleashes a kind of they're effectively
irreversible
chain reaction through a population so
again now you can imagine now this is
like
super dual use because you can imagine
attempts to modify
mosquitoes so that they can't transmit
malaria
well now over 400 000 people per year
die of malaria
most of them are poor children it's a
huge
uh terrible terrible
cost to humanity if you could do this
that you know would be
amazing on the other hand you know gene
drives you could
you could imagine being weaponized to
take out another country's
agriculture there's all sorts of
nightmare scenarios you can imagine
maybe even doing good trying to do good
like with mosquitoes maybe that would
end up
causing some sort of ecological disaster
so there's all these sorts of questions
and taking them you can understand why
somebody might be afraid of
all these kind of um what's sometimes
called techno fixes
uh to fix problems because you could
think well maybe
what we should do is you know not emit
as much co2 and then we wouldn't have to
geo engineer
and maybe we should you know help people
so that they're not so poor and
susceptible to malaria
and then you don't need to release gene
drive mosquitoes
coming back to the other question you
know this is a good place where a
philosopher of science can come in
because they will know some of the
ethics and
justice literature but also they'll have
a
good understanding of the science
[Music]
yeah well thinking about the institute
for practical ethics uh
you know what places that are are great
areas for
uh philosophers uh philosophers of
science and ethicists and scientists to
work together
i mean there's so many but you know some
of them really stand out
one in particular is of course uh with
ai
and data science uh
it's no secret that data science is
taking over the world
the things that used to be the huge
companies and huge industries that
haven't
also fallen to all the big data
companies
you can then see you know both the the
pluses and the minuses of the
the data revolution um
you know and if we think about the
minuses you can think about
you know in certain countries you have
really repressive
governments going after particular
groups they're really
using ai as a as a weapon you can have
facial recognition
technology you know every street corner
phones can be monitored
with location information who you've
texted who you've not texted
and there's all these kind of more
speculative types of technology
such as that don't currently work all
that well
but things like go right from your dna
to drawing your face
now of course it doesn't work all that
well because
you know your path through life might
change their face whether you have a
beard or not or a scar
or you're heavy or heavy or thick or
something like that
but still all of these things can add up
to the
probability being higher and higher that
you you pass in front of a camera
and the chinese government knows that
you
are a member of the uyghur population
that might know that you've started
going
out your back door rather than your
front door all sorts of other things you
know those affect recognition systems
happening and again being used in
some schools in different countries
where
students are being you know monitored
and
you know whether they're happy or or not
is sort of being read off
uh whether they're paying attention uh
all these things can be
you know read off from your uh you know
these systems that are looking at you
again you have the dual use issue some
of these things might be really useful
you know so if it's one if it's an
affect recognition system and it's
put into your car and it tells you you
know
craig you're falling asleep now maybe
pull over
well you know there and if i get to
control whether it's on or off on that
then really that you know it seems like
it's a really
useful device on the other hand you can
imagine all these ways in which it can
be
disastrous
[Music]
it's hard not to get depressed about
thinking about you know the
climate you know when you look at
you know how long we've known about
climate change and
not only have we not done that much we
as those of us from countries who have
put out most of it and have most of the
capability of doing something
about renting it in yeah we've made
things worse
and so that's kind of the way it is with
almost all of the big environmental
problems
is that we recognize the problem
and then instead of fixing it we tend to
make things even worse
and so you could think of also things
like plastic
and plastic pollution and stuff and we
just keep
putting out more and more plastic we
keep putting out more and more co2
and so it's hard not to get depressed on
the other hand
so i teach environmental ethics and i
have i taught environmental ethics for
the first time in
1994 and
well back then you know that we would
think about nuclear energy and stuff
and didn't even talk about climate
change much uh
but you know when i teach all the
students
i mean i i do come away you know i read
all the material
all the climate science and it becomes
very depressing
but then i go into the classroom and
meet all these young students
with all these ideas and that and i walk
out of the classroom optimistic
and so i sort of shift back and forth
from looking at the
you know if i zoom way out then i'm
always very
pessimistic but then when i meet all
these students
then do start to see some reasons for
optimism
i mean do seem to see a shift in things
more and more uh big entities are trying
to
be a bit more green uh
of course sometimes that's just of just
green washing
but in other cases it's really not you
know so for instance the
town i live in i think next year
the older residents will have their
electricity sourced entirely from
renewables
which that's amazing
how many of these things are scalable
i'm not sure that there you can get
depressed a little
bit again but um
you can definitely see signs of op for
optimism
for me if i had to pick one thing that
makes me a bit optimistic
it's the fact that the
economic growth and carbon emissions
uh decoupled many years ago and so it
used to be that you thought that
if you had to decrease carbon emissions
you're sinking a country's economic
growth
now maybe that would be okay for rich
countries like the us
and britain but you know you it's
it was a hard it's hard thing to argue
that people in poorer areas
should have you know not have the
benefits of
a better life because you know your
country
has put all the you know you use the co2
sync
already now but now if if the
if you have this of decoupling between
growth and
and co2 emissions you know that there's
you don't have to make that kind of hard
bargain anymore
and so i i do think that you could have
growth without co2 emissions going up
that's really really big that's that's a
that's a huge
thing to hold on to if you're trying to
find some reason to be optimistic
when you're looking forward for more
debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv